now let me say something inflammatory
that's going to make everyone else react
[Music]
people that I know in real life those
people are people too and we're here
we've been around going outside wearing
only body paint is really similar to
having insecurities to grow up in a
society and a culture that's very frank
about the way you look changes the way
you perceive your personal relationship
with beauty the parts of me that don't
fit in are the parts that make be unique
learn to love yourself for more than
just your body old bodies no matter the
size that shape their ability you know
if you're healthy and you're feeling
good and you've got nothing to hide this
proves that we need to show more body
inclusivity on fashion ads because it
shows that you can be beautiful at any
side I'm most excited to be outside of
my body and see myself walking down the
runway and say like hey pepper is cool
like look at her she's like super
confident it feels a little bit strange
obviously talking about something as
intimate as masturbation but I think
it's a really healthy thing with makeup
without makeup and
both of the slide equally please turn
the light on for every single item on
there is more expensive than you have a
normally heat so I get a fee because I
have no money yep so you're charging
people from being poured welcome to
modern sex
let's put stuff in your mouth head zips
for the very first time pretty recently
please just get me a caramel crap I
thought you said there were tiny
calories it did that embarrassing state
me that you gotta hide your face simple
answers yes
modesty of anybody is ready to try to
leave my wallet you may now kiss the
bride oh my god it's a disaster I'm
hearing something dungeon huh we're
probably not gonna continue to have sex
every day looking to spit on me just
spit on me oh my god bleeding first
blood
[Music]
[Applause]